[Music]
my name is Vivian I'm a product manager
in Google cloud and I have a ad Hammond
senior Enterprise Architect from Colonel
house today here with me as well so from
the title of the session you probably
can expect we're gonna talk a lot about
an industry highly regulated with a lot
of security and compliance requirements
so today we're gonna break it into three
parts the first part will talk about how
Google cloud supports an industry with a
high security and compliance
requirements and then add welcomes and
share his best practice in kernel health
how he improves developers productivity
without compromising their compliance
and security requirements and third part
we'll bring it back to GCP marketplace
and share with you how developers and
enterprise procurement team can benefit
from the marketplace with their
deployment as well as procurement
support okay so let's get started so as
we all know security and compliance is a
collaboration is a shared responsibility
between cloud and customer depending on
the deployment model that you choose why
there is infrastructure as a service or
platform as a service or software as a
service the responsibilities break out
between cloud and customer are different
and the Google cloud does a lot of work
to make sure that our part is secure
meta compliance requirements so it can
better to support you when you need to
meet your compliance and security
so more specifically we do wrong from
the three parts the first part is
protection protection is done when
google cloud design is infrastructure
the security is in the design is build
in a part of the design from the chips
should compute networking storage to the
data center we have security built into
all of these designs and also control
GCP offers a wide range of control for
you to meet your policy regulatory and
business objectives and the last part is
compliance as mentioned we work to meet
our compliance requirements so that we
can better to support you and make your
compliance work easier so just give you
an example we know that our customer and
the regulator expect us to work with the
third-party independent auditor to look
at our compliance to make sure that of
our policy our operation our
infrastructure are all meeting their
security privacy compliance requirements
so that's reason that you can see here
we have regularly work with the
third-party auditors to do all the
certification and compliance and that
includes post internationally globally
accepted compliance standards as well as
regional local standards so that make
you when you need to meet those your
side of standards and compliance
requirements easier when you either go
global or you go to the Pacific region
and we continue to expand this list and
at the same time you probably recognize
some of the partners name here there are
top-notch security partners that we are
working with they are probably already
in your on-prem data center so when you
move to
GCP cloud those partner solutions are on
GCP marketplace as well so you can have
a consistency between your own friends
the dead center and cloud you can have
the same security posture and cloud
technology from Louie from the feedback
that we collect from the customer really
represent a fundamental shift for the
healthcare transitionally on the on Prem
environment you have an inflexible
software deployment right it's very hard
to deploy to update to your patch and as
a result of that most of the developers
a lot of developers cycle goes into
maintaining that infrastructure instead
of developing business focused
applications and solutions and as a
result of that you have you might have a
complex rigid offers and also data are
siloed it's hard to get a holistic view
of your patient information of your
system of your solution and also is
mailing harp expects so it usually goes
through long truble cycle with a large
procurement team within your
organization with a cloud the promise of
Google Cloud cost-reduction universal
access up-to-date and flexibility we see
some of our healthcare customer are
moving to a new model the model that
build on top of cloud so with that model
first of all software is very easy to
deploy it's very easy to maintain patch
or update and as a result of that you
save the time from maintaining
infrastructure you save the time from
patching your software the developer can
really focus on your true IP focus on
business value applications and with
that you also start to have data coming
together form a patient centric view how
you can view your data everywhere
anytime you
need or your customer need so with us
being sad I want to welcome back to the
stage and he was share with you how he
improved the developer's agility in
colonel health without sacrificing any
security and compliance thanks thank you
can you hear me you got me all right
there we go we're glad to have you all
here hopefully this will be of value to
you if you don't know anything about
Cardinal health Cardinal health is a
large health care company and we're
concerned about providing products and
services to hospitals and solution
providers and we are multinational you
can read the slide up here so this talk
what we're trying to focus in on here is
who is going to try and use this
information really our goal is to try
and help the centralized IT staff as
well as the distributed staff we have
people all over the country all over the
world there are supporting IT
capabilities then at various different
stages in their sophistication so simple
developers full DevOps teams or
researchers for example Truby AI
researchers AI researchers or architects
I'm an architect so I I play around more
than new operational things and what we
really want to try and do is get the
consistency when we deploy things out we
want to have consistent framework
consistency is always good in data
processing we also want to have
efficiency because we're really cost
conscious obviously and so we want to be
able to maximize the utility of the
things that we develop use once our
build once we use and then zeroed
already I had this zero to 60 but 60
what zero to 60 in 60 seconds
so that you can actually deploy an
instance very very quickly almost on the
competitive nature of what you might do
for a container
and ensure that we have a secure
environment okay so about security
security is all about protecting our
customer data there are lots of
regulations out there they care about us
trying to protect the customer data and
we have to have multiple layers of
defense you don't want to have a single
Mis configuration create disaster so you
have to put several different things in
place obviously you have to have logging
monitoring compliance audit all those
kinds of things
there are HIPPA requirements that you
have to KITT maintain certain audit logs
for seven years some other data has to
be maintained for 40 or 50 years that
kind of thing so you have to think about
all these kinds of considerations and we
use several products in our ecosystem to
try and provide that multiple layers of
disent defense but by the same token we
want to go cloud native as much as we
possibly can so we can test new and
different products we heard about anthos
we've also heard this just this morning
about new artificial intelligence bi
kinds of capabilities so we want to take
advantage of those very very quickly so
we really like the page to go model one
of my executives I have it on the slide
he talks about it as being a disposable
technology stack but pay-as-you-go means
the zero commitment
traditionally if you're going to try and
get something you had to go in this
year-long or three-year long kind of
contract cycle in this world I can use
it for three months and then deploy
something different if I need to now
traditional technologies really haven't
caught up with this this is a real
challenge for a lot of the vendors some
of the vendors that you saw in the
Vivien's earlier slide they still sort
of trying move you toward a one or
three-year or five-year commit on
purchasing some of the licenses so we as
an industry trying to need to help
vendors move into this pay-as-you-go
model it's gonna be a challenge for us
all when you start talking about
infrastructure as code everybody needs
to become a programmer what I mean by
that is rather than have
you know Windows Systems Administrator
try and work with the Windows GUI
everything needs to be in code
everything needs to be in get you push
it up the whole whole instance is fully
configured we do that for Linux we do it
for Linux the windows and so forth so
again protecting our customers we use
standard approaches because we we're
lifting and shifting a lot of our
workloads from on-premise data centers
into the cloud and when you do that you
can't change all everything all at once
so therefore there are tools and
techniques they have been used
traditionally in some of those security
appliances that we just can't throw away
that we have to maintain and there is
not a cloud native equivalent so we had
to bring those appliances forward with
us and they're used largely for the
segmentation there's some business
function put in there but it's largely
for segmentation and isolation or
workloads there's also the challenge of
separation of duties you hear a
separation of duties and quite often you
think about two different groups doing
things right this group has to do
firewall rules this group has to do this
this is a test team and that kind of
thing well when you think about DevOps
and everybody being a programmer and
click a button and now I have a full
production environment that really
challenges that separation of duties so
therefore you have to put into place CIT
CD workflows and checkpoints approval
checkpoints to make sure somebody
doesn't release something incorrectly or
either maliciously or accidentally we
also develop standard patterns we vent
that we think about it we design it we
test it we develop standard patterns and
we want to deploy those consistent basis
so we use something called golden images
you could call it whatever you want it's
or like a a CD that you can use that has
everything on it that you would need it
that also helps prevent the common
mistakes that you're going to naturally
have we also put that in the network as
well
to ensure that we don't have an
accidental thing get through obviously
that would be a bad thing
we have reactive controls as well there
I'll give you a case in point in the in
the network if somebody puts in a
network firewall rule that's incorrect
we have cloud functions that
automatically shuts those down within
seconds we do the same thing in some of
our images as well okay
so the golden images let me talk about
that one we take the marketplace images
and we have a number of them that we
support we take those marketplace images
and we use Packer and we add onto that
marketplace image a number of different
security products and number of
different configuration items that are
necessary to run a VM instance in the
environment we take those and we have
them as a private image family and we
share that authorized use give
permissions to service projects
authorized that use to the service
project so developers can just pick
those off the off the shelf and they
have everything that they need to be
secured so again we apply hardening CIS
hardening scripts we install binaries
and other products that we need to have
on there that are required for security
compliance purposes in Windows we we
sysprep the images or in Linux we redact
out some configuration items and then we
do automated pen testing we actually
deploy some of these and do pen testing
afterwards to make sure it's all all
solid we try and do this on a monthly
basis it's pretty much automated but
with things changing you know some
technologies change there's some manual
in there as well but generally it's
fairly well automated that when a new
image comes out we update it the other
advantage about this is once we put that
up there the boot image so licensing
material that needs to be there that's
maintained with these images so there's
no additional
effort on the developer standpoint to
deploy something now for special use
cases we have some security appliances
which are really special use cases they
have many network adapters they have
many many considerations that you have
to take into account we took the gold
nimita that took the image off the
marketplace that's provided by the
vendor and we have a bash script fairly
simple bash script that runs deployment
manager and the real physics is in that
yamo file in the ammo file we put in all
the material that we need to customize
that image I use the term boilerplate
settings but it's all the things that
you need to do for example up something
silly like on every system image you
have to have the disclaimer that your
your actions can be monitored right
that's the legal requirement you have to
everybody has that on their systems so
that has to be on every single image
where are the DNS servers how you doing
ntp all that kind of stuff is part of
this boilerplate every image should get
this kind of material so I put that all
in the CMO file and so from 0 to 60 in
11 minutes and that's what three reboots
because I'm switching network adapters
and provisioning modules and resizing
disk drives and that kind of stuff
within eleven minutes you can have a
fully production security appliance
deployed and ready to go from 0 to 60
and 11 minutes that's pretty powerful
give you an example just last week we
have brand new engineer come on very
skilled networking very skilled in
working with this class of appliance and
she had never seen getting before so I
sat where there for an hour and a half
going over again having her to
understand get and Bosch and that kind
of thing but once we went through that
she was able to actually use the
deployment and build two instances in 11
minutes
so it was pretty straightforward once I
got her past all the you're now a
programmer she was able to do her job
very very effectively so therefore she
didn't have to go and figure out all the
CMO boilerplate and everything else
traditionally when you think about
deploying some of these hardware
appliances it's several hours of
somebody going through and configuring
this and configuring that and so forth
and so on so infrastructure is code
really pays the value so another one
that we were worried about is once you
put one of these appliances out there
what happens if you have a disk drive
failure right that's always a worry and
in the physical world you have to disk
drives and you have an active standby
pair and those kinds of things well in
the cloud you don't have this act to
standby pair everything's active active
ok so what happens if you lose a disk
drive well we take snapshots we're doing
hourly snapshots so the disk drive gets
corrupted which hour do you want me to
recreate from with the yeah mo file
deployment answer we can destroy rebuild
inside of five minutes so if if today
right the second somebody called me and
say I need to rebuild from seven hours
ago I could take it five minutes you got
it back again that's pretty powerful
on each one of our instances we have all
the logging and monitoring tools this
little icon there's representative of
one the very common large-scale logging
and monitoring tools that many people
use but we also use stackdriver we also
use cloud storage as a logging and
monitoring for example I mentioned that
in some cases we have retention periods
of you know many years seven forty fifty
years of retention it doesn't make sense
to maintain on Brown spinning disk makes
its sorry
makes sense put in cloud storage so that
you can have that really long retention
okay now of course you're going to apply
life cycles to all that so that you're
gonna throw away data that you don't
need as quickly as you need to okay so
the buying models how many people have
ever tried to you know you get something
and they say we'll give you a 30-day
free trial you know and so forth and so
on I don't know about you by never ever
not once ever had a 30 day free trial
not getting extended two or three times
so typically what you need is you need
five hours of dedicated time over a
hundred twenty day period right I I
don't know about you about I get busy
and I run from meeting to meeting a
meeting well in this this case what I
can actually do is I can spin up an
instance work on it for an hour shut it
down go to meetings go off to a
conference for a week come back
run it for another hour and that kind of
thing so I have it over a long duration
again we were talking about this
disposable technology so one of the
things as we start adopting the cloud
we've been on this journey for several
years now is we did not want to get into
a position where I make a technology
decision today and I continue with that
technology just because I hadn't bought
it one of the challenges you run into is
as soon as you buy it then you wind up
using more of it which means you are
locked into it and we want to be able to
get out of that vendor lock-in kind of
case so when we start thinking about
some of these security appliances
when I start I say great that's my
current architecture for today if Google
comes out with a competitive advantage
I'm gonna drop that one flip over to
this other one and so I don't want to be
stuck into a particular technology now
that actually challenges if you think
about it the traditional purchasing
model alright so in our case we're a
trek publicly traded company and certain
layers of management have certain spend
authorities I'm sure you probably have
the same kind of thing and in the old
capex model it was well you have to do a
capital purchase request it has to go
through procurement has to get 12
signatures and so forth and so on some
of these appliances can be fairly
expensive one of them as I've shown here
is $85 a day well after you know I spend
out five or six of these things run them
for several days if my manager doesn't
have the proper spend Authority now it
can be a problem so you constantly have
to go through education of people to
make sure that they understand what
you're spending and turn off the lights
I talk about this all the time to the
people then your mom and dad ever tell
you at off the lights when you leave the
room we need to always turn off the
lights whenever we possibly can we do
that across the board we have a number
of tools that we use to try and turn off
the lights automatically based on time
and also based on utilization but the
other notion is build it only when you
need it don't build it two weeks in
advance build it the day or the hour or
the minute that you need it and then
destroy it as quickly as you possibly
can that's a really different mindset if
you ever worked with any project team a
store example I was working with one for
our e-commerce team and they were saying
we have to have all these servers built
you know we have to have 10 servers this
way and so forth and so on and I said
well ok when do you need them on Friday
and I said ok what time on Friday they
said well by Friday afternoon ok I'll
build them at lunch time no no no we
need them by Monday why because that's
what we do we have to get them on Monday
that's the project you get them
my name we'll use them on Friday and
said no I'm gonna do it at lunchtime so
again that that model is very different
for most enterprises so my summary slide
the advantage of the advice for others I
would recommend the concept of the
golden images now there are exceptions
for example I was I was just mentioning
there's a lot of chatter this morning on
an email back home somebody wants to use
an image off the straight marketplace
and I said great you will use an image
off the marketplace then you get to go
through the five pages of steps that we
go through to build the golden image but
I don't want to do that well then your
choice is to use a golden image so we're
calling these not standards we call
these accelerators trying to make it a
positive experience if you use the
accelerator you go fast if you deviate
from that news something different it's
gonna slow you down have a solid
maintenance pattern of how you're gonna
actually deploy these things how are you
actually going to use them and
communicate that with your customers we
use share templates for common
deployments in deployment manager we
have a standard template and in
literally in about 12 lines of yamo the
host name and whatever you're going to
want what network you want to put it on
in about 12 lines the ammo that's all
you need to spin up an instance and you
can get it in two or three minutes
domain joined if it's windows and all
that kind of stuff okay use the power of
the startup script that's how we're
doing some of that and we also use cloud
storage very heavily for example another
one is somebody want to create their own
troop return a notebook okay so they
want to create a set of images for that
so what we did was we use a golden image
and to do the Jupiter notebook it was a
61 gigabyte file that they needed to
install so we put that cloud storage
when the instant boots up the quote
downloads it from cloud storage
configures it there you go
in the last note that I might say is if
your folks are not programmers they need
to become so it's going to be a
challenge to to not have programmers in
your enterprise so that means the skills
uplift at times it means training it
means patience with people learning how
to use tools like yet and manage
infrastructure is code so well meet have
some time to take questions later on and
I'm going to turn it back over to video
I went back sorry thank you so much at
it's always exciting to see how GCP
empowered enterprise and learn from the
best practice from those enterprise so
i'd mentions you know they start their
deployment from GCP marketplace so I
want you just deep dive a little bit
more to the GCP marketplace and also
share other capabilities of the GCP
marketplace with you so we built the GCP
marketplace really for enterprise
development we enable the developers
productivity right we have those weather
to test the solutions on GCP marketplace
they can download and use it right away
we have the simplified management so we
will talk about the deployment manager
and also mentioned that's something they
use as well as some new capability in
the kubernetes application and at the
end I think this is a for everyone
enable procurement billing invoicing
procurement budget approval is never
really a fun process so GCP marketplace
try to simplify that for you okay so
let's look at a developer experience
first as mentioned there's a very rich
catalog of solutions on GCP marketplace
there's a lot of category and it covers
a wide range of a vertical and in terms
of form factor we have a VM solutions
kubernetes applications data size API
software as a service right so any form
factor you can think of you will need
to build your application you can find
them in marketplace and second the
deployment manager had already you know
show the deployment manager in his
example that can simplify your
deployment but one is required it really
allows you to do very powerful
customization as well for example
building the golden image and embedded
golden image into the deployment manager
in Colonel house example and the last
one is the kubernetes application very
happy to announce is going GA the
kubernetes application on GCP
marketplace we work very hard with a lot
of partners to make this another type of
solution on GCP and we also have the
simplified manage the update for you in
alpha so the reason that we work so hard
to get a bonanza application onto GCP
marketplace because we heard from you
that you want a solution that you just
need to build a once and it can run
anywhere so we did that with a vanessa's
application you can run that application
in your own crime environment on top of
anthos or on any kubernetes clusters and
you have the flexibility to move that
solution between those environments as
well and the kubernetes application also
has the pre-built template deployment
template into the application so that
simplifies your deployment experience
and the last again this will be another
line item in your GC PPO together with
the gcpd resource used use together with
the other partner solution you use so
you have a consolidated billing in one
invoice form TCP and talking about a
manager updates right we understand the
deployment is not enough what you really
need
management is the lifecycle management
so we are introducing manage to updates
for kubernetes application so we are
introducing manager update for
kubernetes application first of all you
can leverage that capability through our
GCP UI as you can see on a screenshot it
allows you to patch any security
vulnerability or any updates to your
application much quickly and the second
this manager update has the auto
rollback capability so you define the
rollback condition any condition you
need and GCP will do the house check for
your application once the condition is
matched the auto rollback trigger will
happen right so you don't have to
monitor your system very closely as long
as you define your condition very well
because the robot will happen
automatically once the GCP detects that
and the last it's the current manager
update is supported on the COI as well
as the GCP UI front so as a developer if
you want to integrate that into your
system using the CLI that's available ok
so since we talked about the entos just
a kind of a recap and those is a google
build google manage software stack and
it allows you to deliver your
applications into our hybrid and multi
cloud environment so it has the
automated a policy and a security
building so you can do the policy
management and security management at
scale and it also has a very consistent
operational management or consists in
the control plane experience you need
when you go across multiple environment
and of course we always build a
ecosystem around a solution that we
deliver and those has a very strong very
powerful enterprise ecosystem
and as you can see kubernetes
application as you know one of the core
into anthos has already so many partners
offering their solutions on GCP
marketplace and the customers are
looking at those two bananas application
and can deploy it easily using the
deployment of the kubernetes manager the
update can use our tools to easily
spinning them up and down in their
environment and also as and those
promised we are doing hybrid cloud you
not only can deploy your application
into GCP gke but also the gke on kram
and a we made that happen with our
partners as well for the partners in
this year not only you can deploy them
in the GAE ultra in GCP as well as the
GAE on pram and we are working with the
rest of the kubernetes application
partners very hard to make them their
solution available on pram so this way
you really have the consistency across
different environment whether it's a
customer build application that you
build yourself or a partner solution
that you are getting from the
marketplace ok so just if you
marketplace we talked a lot about the
kubernetes up but GCP marketplace is
really has a lot more other solutions
just to remind we have a vm we have SAS
we have an api we have a data set and
that covers a wide range of use case so
it's from security database networking
storage machine learning AI Big Data you
name it right we can we have all type of
partners offering this solutions on the
GCP marketplace so we talked about the
developer it's easy to use from the
marketplace from the developer point of
view what about an enterprise first of
all we have a very flexible pricing
model as I'd mentioned earlier they want
usage based they want to have a disposal
technology
disposal means I'm not wasting anything
if I switch my technology stack and
usage-based pricing allow you or
pay-as-you-go allow you to do that
there is no pre-commitment there's no
pre contract negotiation or a very long
packet approval you can just use and pay
for what you use then the second is we
understand when you move to production
when you have a more stable environment
you probably need a more consistent
billing model so this is a where we
provide a monthly subscription we
provide you and your subscription
multi-year subscription and an annual
subscription is coming in beta very soon
so this way you will get the consistency
you need when you move into your
production environment and second we
know that you work with your vendor
pretty closely and the most of time you
might have custom contract you have
custom pricing so this is aware we allow
you to continue to leverage the CP
marketplace right you don't have to go
to another channel go to another
procurement process because you have a
discount negotiating with your vendor so
in using a private pricing your vendor
can create a code inside the GCP and
deliver that a code chill you through
GCP and all the transaction or the
procurement will still happen
using the GCP billing system and europe
eventually the vendor charge will also
show up on the GCP bill so preserve this
is a single peel benefits you can from
TCP and the last one is a private
catalog I'd mention that they have those
coding image they try to put into a
catalog so that their developer can
easily leverage them we are building
that a service as well right now to make
that even that process easier so the
private car lock will allow you to put
your golden image into that with the
right access and control and your
developer can just grab it from the
private color
and a private eye lock right now is in
beta so just want to show you some
example you know Colonel health is not
only an example using TCP marketplace
where you have a increasing number of
large enterprise customers are deploying
their solution looking their entire
product lifecycle from development to
production and looking those solution
from the marketplace we are looking
we're seeing developers are getting
their building blocks from TCP
marketplace whether it's a tooling
whether it's a farm or whether it's a
load balancer whether it's a database
and we're seeing the IT operation also
deploying solution from the GCP
marketplace because they see the ease of
deployment and management and risk free
a few work capability just to mention on
the integration that we do with the
other DCP services cloud security
command center so this is a GCP service
provide you a single pane of glass for
the threats that you might have in a
system then take action immediately not
only you can deploy or provisions cloud
security command center from TCP
marketplace but also we integrate some
of the security partner solution into
the command center so as a result of
that not only you see your GCP resource
how their security posture is and a
ticket actually on it you can also see
your vendor security solution so you
have a complete picture about your
environment
and as you have heard from a keynote we
will also welcome those open source
partner to GCP marketplace not only they
will have the same ease of use from the
GCP marketplace consolidated appealing
but also will offer additional first
party experience to make you when you
use those open source experience really
great and we also want to welcome the
newest kubernetes absolution from Palo
Alto this is the security adapter Palo
Alto offers on the service mesh and
again this is a solution on GCP
marketplace but you can deploy either on
GCP or the GK erm so this is already
running fully integrated with our ento
solution and we want to walk on more and
new and updated listing this list just
growing by the day every day we have a
new partner either adding their
solutions additional solutions to the
marketplace or new partner with the new
solution coming on board great so I've
been talking about an enterprise
developers but just in case you are
actually have a solution please come
sell-on GCP marketplace as you can see
with the GCP first of all global
visibility increased global sell his
solution delivery we do have a high bar
to make sure that your solution is
secure and easy to deploy and you have a
lot of GTM opportunities with a Google
so just to recap Google Cloud provides a
product solution templates best practice
to support you with the high
requirements and compliance and kernel
add from kernel hell shared their best
practice how to improve the developers
experience to improve the developer
agility without sacrificing anything on
security and compliance and the last GCP
markula marketplace is your catalog for
any
application solutions you need to build
your own business
[Music]